Public Sénat et écho DDS vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les cours
responsables sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle d'une
ressource vitale que l'on croyait
inépuisable l'eau sécheresse extrême
nappe phréatique au plus bas et robinet
à sec dans plus d'une centaine de
communes l'été 2022 Marc plus que jamais
un tournant et nous rappelle au combien
l'eau est en danger alors comment a-t-on
pu en arriver là faut-il désormais
s'habituer à manquer d'eau réponse avec
l'hydrologue et maziza comment le groupe
sort numéro 3 français de la
distribution et du traitement de l'eau
qu'il traverse cette crise comment
a-t-il accompagné les collectivités les
industriels qui sont retrouvés avec le
robinet coupé son président nous
racontera cet été pas comme les autres
enfin chasse aux fuites recyclage et
dessalement de l'eau passage en revue
des solutions qui peuvent nous aider à
sauver notre orbe bleu mais d'abord tout
ce qu'il faut savoir sur l'eau en France
en moins d'une minute c'est parti la
France un pays arrosé nous sommes bien
l'outil avec 512 milliards de mètres
cubes depuis par an mais sur ces 512
milliards 60% s’évaporent et 40% forment
la pluie efficace qui alimente cours
d'eau et nappe phréatique dans ces eaux
disponibles nous puisons 32 milliards de
mètres cubes par an dont 5 sont affectés
à l'eau potable malheureusement 20% sont
perdus à cause des fuites dans les
canalisations
et quels sont les plus gros
consommateurs d'eau l'agriculture
accapare presque la moitié arrivant
ensuite l'usage domestique puis le
secteur de l'énergie et enfin le secteur
industriel
et nous à notre échelle comment
consomme-t-on l'eau chaque foyer
consomme 329 litres d'eau par jour soit
200 litres pour laver sa voiture jusqu'à
200 litres pour le bain 100 litres pour
la douche et 12 pour les toilettes un
lave-vaisselle lui pompe jusqu'à 40
litres et un lave-linge jusqu'à 140
litres enfin le plus gourmand reste
l'arrosage du jardin avec 2000 litres
d'eau non pas par jour mais par heure
[Musique]
trois vagues de chaleur 33 jours de
canicule des températures hors normes
l'été a été suffocant qui dit canicule
extrême dit augmentation bien sûr de la
consommation d'eau mais aussi
évaporation des cours d'eau et donc
menace sur notre eau potable et Mazy
bonjour merci d'être là avec nous vous
êtes hydrologue et fondatrice et
présidente de Mayan cet été nous a dit
météo France a été le deuxième le plus
chaud après 2003 qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui sont ces petits qui
disent que tout ça est assez
exceptionnel et que ça n'a pas forcément
se reproduire en leur dit quoi on leur
dit qu'il faut peut-être regarder les
années qui viennent de s'écouler et que
chaque année nous raconte une nouvelle
histoire de la France lorsqu'on regarde
l'empreinte cette année de la sécheresse
on voit que le Maroc est concerné
l'Espagne est concerné la Belgique 95%
du territoire de la Belgique a démarré
l'été avec une sécheresse extrêmement
sévère faut imaginer que en Belgique on
est dans un territoire humide
habituellement donc en fait il y a
quelque chose de nouveau qui se joue et
puis les territoires dans lesquels on
imaginez un impact potentiel du
changement climatique ne sont pas ceux
que l'on voit actuellement se mettre en
place par exemple la Bretagne regardons
les températures qui ont été atteints ou
encore la Grande-Bretagne cet été donc
on imaginait en fait que ce changement
climatique elle est surtout concerné
pour tous méditerranéen et on se rend
compte qu'on est absolument pas prêt
parce que toute la métropole est
concernée cette année on a tous les
éléments on a un hiver où on n'a pas de
recharge dans nos nappes phréatiques
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas cette
capacité de pouvoir tenir au printemps
et jusqu'à l'été avec des recharges qui
normalement arrivent l'hiver elles ne
sont pas arrivées et ça c'est vraiment
la première fois ensuite on cumule des
mois entiers sans pluie des températures
toujours hors normes regardons le mois
de mai c'était le mois de mai le plus
chaud jamais enregistré en France et là
on était encore avant le mois de juin
qui nous a annoncé une nouvelle canicule
et pourtant il y a eu des signes
avant-coureurs depuis quelques années
qu'on n'a pas voulu le voir et en même
temps je me rappelle qu'en 2021 il a
énormément plu
alors 2021 est une année très
particulière parce qu'effectivement on a
eu ce que l'on appelle des phénomènes de
goût de froide ce sont des anomalies
météorologiques qui se positionnent en
général au large de l'Atlantique et qui
génère des pluies très importantes elles
ont généré des précipitations sur
l'ensemble de la France par contre en se
chargeant en eau ces basses couches
d'air ont été poussés en direction de
l'Allemagne et de la Belgique et donc
ont été à l'origine de la catastrophe
donc il faut comprendre que ce qui est
arrivé sur la France c'est surtout le
résultat d'un air froid qui essaye de se
positionner là où il peut et qui génère
à l'inverse des catastrophes extrêmes
qui vont dans l'autre sens mais si on
prend un tout petit peu plus de hauteur
on avait à ce moment là un dôme de
chaleur en Espagne des températures
caniculaires partout que ce soit le
Maroc des feux en Tunisie y maîtrisables
on avait tout l'Italie et toute la
péninsule
ibérique qui était vraiment dans un état
extrême donc on voit qu'à un moment
donné rappelons-nous des images de la
Grèce d'Athènes en 2021 donc ça a été
malgré tout l'année la plus chaude
jamais enregistrée en Europe même si en
France on n'a pas été concerné il y a
avant et un après encore une fois ce
qu'on a vécu cet été
on sait pas où il faut être modeste dire
qu'on ne sait pas
de ce que l'on voit en tous les cas et
ce qui se dessine c'est une nouvelle
tendance une tendance ou chaque année il
y a des éléments nouveaux mais par
contre des températures toujours plus
chaudes et donc c'est sûr que si on
regarde ce qui se passe au dessus de nos
têtes on peut voir de la pluie et on
peut voir m'ont donné une bulle d'air
froid et si on prend un tout petit peu
de hauteur on se rend bien compte qu'il
y a une quelque chose qui est en train
de se jouer qui nous dépasse qui est de
l'ordre de leur norme et qui surtout
arrive sur des territoires où on n'est
pas préparé en France on n'est pas prêt
parce que on est habitué à boire
beaucoup d'eau 512 milliards de mètres
cubes d'eau annuel et donc si on ne les
a plus on ne sait pas comment faire et
la nouveauté c'est effectivement que le
fait que plus aucune région française ne
soit à l'abri vous évoquée effectivement
la Bretagne Brest quasiment 40 degrés
voilà même la Normandie enfin je veux
dire exactement moi ce qui m'a
énormément marqué c'est en 2019 les feux
que l'on avait qui se déclarait dans les
champs en Picardie on n'est pas prêt en
termes de sécurité civile à faire face
justement à ces déclenchements de feu
parce que toute la sécurité civile est à
ce moment-là durant l'été sur le
pourtour méditerranéen et sur l'accord
donc ça signifie qu'il va falloir
beaucoup plus de moyens de sécurité
civile qui se déploie sur l'ensemble du
territoire et surtout qu'on soit prêt
partout même si on ne sait pas où ça
arrivera majoritairement c'est un modèle
pour nous pour vous l'Espagne le
Portugal puisque eux-mêmes ont dû faire
face avant nous à ce mur
à cette canicule cette sécheresse et ce
manque d'eau quand on regarde
l'agriculture en Espagne je suis pas sûr
que ce soit un modèle au Maroc ont
surexploite massivement les nappes tout
comme en Espagne je crois qu'il faut
regarder ces exemples comme peut-être
des exemples que sur lesquels on ne
voudrait pas effectivement aller comme
une trajectoire tout comme la Californie
ou l'Australie on a j'ai envie de dire
maltraité le cycle de l'eau c'est à dire
qu'on a oublié un moment donné quelque
chose qui est essentiel c'est à quel
point il est il est important que cette
eau elle pénétrer dans les sols pour ça
il ne faut pas artificialiser nos sols
et lorsque l'on voit toute cette
bétonisation effectivement on se rend
compte du chantier qui reste devant nous
elle va finir par tomber de ça parce que
l'automne va arriver
la pluie ne nourrit pas bien la terre
parce que il y a trop de béton enfin
c'est il va arriver avec cette période
automnale c'est vraiment le fait qu'on
est des précipitations souvent
diluvienne
il y en a trop elle ruisselle dans un
premier temps et donc elle génère des
inondations souvent violentes notamment
sur les routes dans tous les axes où
l'eau essaie de s'infiltrer ensuite dans
un deuxième temps elle va effectivement
être absorbée par le territoire qui est
une véritable éponge qui a soif donc le
territoire est capable d'avaler des
millions et des millions de mètres cubes
d'eau et puis à un moment donné quand le
territoire se ressentir à nouveau et
bien on a les inondations
catastrophiques que l'on peut connaître
dans le pourtour méditerranéen donc j'ai
envie de dire que c'est la vers et le
revers d'une même médaille et donc
attention
à cette à se dérèglement du cycle de
l'eau qui génère le fait qu'on est soit
trop peu soit trop d'eau et donc il faut
effectivement retirer
cet hiver oui et non parce que elles
seront rechargées uniquement dans les
zones où on aura des précipitations
c'est toutes les autres zones où il ne
pleut pas et bien la sécheresse va
continuer et il ne faut jamais oublier
qu'une nappe qui se tarit peut mettre
jusqu'à 10 ans avant de se renouveler et
de se rééquilibrer et comme chaque année
elle subit un nouveau une nouvelle
sécheresse elle a de plus en plus de mal
à trouver son équipe donc on va manquer
d'eau encore une fois c'est pas joie se
faire peur on va manquer d'eau je pense
beaucoup moins d'eau et qu'il va falloir
beaucoup mieux gérer l'eau c'est à dire
regarder maintenant qui sont les les
véritables utilisateurs de l'eau décidé
ensemble de qui seront prioritaires dans
des phases de manque intense et surtout
décider de la trajectoire que l'on veut
de ce commun qui est l'eau et qui
appartient à tout le monde mais surtout
milieu naturel et on a tendance à
l'oublier
politiques peut-être à la clé pour
lutter contre ce qu'on appelle les
inégalités territoriales en matière
d’eau et de stress hydrique il faut ça
existe je sais pas il faut plus de
comment dire de solidarité entre les
territoires parce que il y a plus d'eau
à Paris que qu'ailleurs enfin oui entre
les régions entre les collectivités
alors effectivement on est absolument
pas tous égaux face à la question de
l'eau lorsqu'on habite sur le Bassin
parisien ou par exemple sur Nice on est
connecté à des nappes phréatiques qui
sont capables d'être résilientes durant
des décennies et qui pourrait vivre des
sécheresses durant des années et des
années sans pour autant impacter la
ressource en eau de ses habitants et à
10-15 kilomètres de là on peut avoir une
situation qui se transforme complètement
parce qu'on a un sous-sol qui est
différent et donc en réalité on peut
être complètement très vite déconnecté
d'une ressource en dos et ne plus avoir
d'eau dans son robinet alors que
d'autres au contraire vont en avoir
comment est-ce qu'on transporte cette
eau c'est des questions qu'il faut se
poser on est capable d'amener des
scanniositaires dans des petits villages
est-ce qu'on sera capable dans de très
grandes villes on doit se poser ces
questions maintenant parce que ça c'est
ce qui arrive devant nous donc voilà ce
sont des questions essentielles
effectivement moins utilisées d'eau à
notre échelle il existe énormément de
solutions mais il faut le mettre en
oeuvre de manière massive et on a
absolument pas le choix merci maziza
merci hydrologue et fondatrice et
présidente de Maya merci à vous et pour
faire face à ces pénuries d'eau il faut
bien sûr évidemment éviter le gaspillage
avec en amont la chasse aux fuites et en
aval le recyclage de nos eaux usées
manuels
à Durban-Corbières dans l'Aude les
habitants sont touchés de plein fouet
par le dérèglement climatique on a eu
les coupures d'eau la nuit et
l'après-midi toutes les après-midi
pendant un mois et demi l'été nous on
est obligé de fermer le magasin on n'a
pas le choix sans eau on peut pas
travailler à chaque épisode de
sécheresse le salon de coiffure
d'Adeline est sur le film alors pour
éviter de mettre la clé sous la porte la
chef d'entreprise a trouvé la parade
j'ai trouvé un système de pompe à
camping car c'est une petite douchette
c'est une pompe alors je remplis des
bidons d'eau et c'est une pompe ça me
donne un petit peu de pression et ça me
permet de faire quelque shampoings ou
qui entend en attendant la fermeture du
magasin
cet été face à la pénurie d'eau des
milliers de Français ont vu leur
quotidien bouleversé
et pourtant des solutions il en
existerait quelques-unes
j'ai démarré au début de ma rue je
redescendu je croisements à Narbonne
dans une zone pavillonnaire une équipe
un peu spéciale s'active sur la chaussée
à longueur de journée ces techniciens
traquent les fuites d'eau potable dans
les canalisations de la commune on a sur
la ville de Narbonne des compteurs un
peu partout qui nous permettent de
mesurer ce qui entre ce qui sort et donc
là sur ce quartier on a identifié qu'il
y avait un débit d'environ 3 mètres
cubes donc 3000 bouteilles d'eau à
l'heure de fuite en surface rien n'est
visible et pourtant quelque part sous
nos pieds cette fuite ferait perdre à la
commune l'équivalent de 10 piscines
olympiques en eau potable chaque année
c'est parti
reste à déterminer où se situe
précisément la rupture de canalisation
la technique peut sembler archaïque tous
les espoirs repos sur Wilfried au bout
de la tige un micro qui permet d'écouter
ce qui se passe sous le bitume
on doit balayer à peu près toute la
ville une fois par an au moins quoi avec
près de 250 fuites par an à Narbonne où
il frites du métier quelques instants
plus tard il entend une anomalie voici
le son qui caractérise une fuite
et donc les travaux là tu sais s'ils
interviennent aujourd'hui ou demain le
plus rapide normalement cet après-midi
cet après-midi
chaque année à l'échelle nationale
disparaît dans nos canalisations
l'équivalent de la consommation en eau
potable de 18 millions d'habitants pour
faire face à la raréfaction de l'eau les
communes font la chasse aux gâchis mais
elles encouragent également leur
prestataires à innover
nous poursuivons notre enquête dans la
station d'épuration de Narbonne la
France en compte plus de 20 000 comme
celle-ci et toutes ont le même mode de
fonctionnement alors là au niveau du de
la première étape de traitement de la
station d'épuration en fait où toutes
les eaux usées de Narbonne arrivent ici
tout d'abord les déchets sont éliminés
puis les eaux sont traités
biologiquement et chimiquement dans de
gigantesques bassins avant d'être rejeté
dans le milieu naturel
c'est le traitement classique de station
d'épuration en fait ce qu'on appelle
debout activer
puisque là rien d'innovant cette
technique existe depuis plus de 40 ans
mais pour faire face aux conséquences du
changement climatique sur la ressource
en eau Veolia imaginé une étape
supplémentaire qui consisterait à
recycler l'eau au lieu de la rejeter
dans le canal cela s'appelle la réussite
ou réutilisation des eaux usées et elle
se déroule dans ce petit container
maintenant ça peut être jouable
pompe filtre javel à la sortie de ce
container l'eau est purifiée elle
n'atteint pas le niveau de qualité de
l'eau potable mais elle est suffisamment
propre pour la remplacer dans bon nombre
de cas comme pour le nettoyage des
villes l'arrosage des stades la
protection incendie ou encore
l'irrigation agricole
aujourd'hui les Espagnols utilisent
l'eau réutiliser pour notamment irriguer
leur culture de légumes de fruits qui
sont peut-être même consommés en France
par certains de nos concitoyens et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que nous on a une
nécessité de d'accélérer la démarche
parce qu'aujourd'hui si on se projette
dans les 10 ans on aura le climat semi
de l'Espagne en France 1% de l'eau est
recyclée contre 8% en Italie 14 en
Espagne et même 90% en Israël pour
combler son retard Veolia veut installer
d'ici 2023 une centaine de read box
comme celle-ci sur le territoire et
économisez ainsi près de 3 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau chaque année soit
l'équivalent de la consommation d'une
ville de 180 000 habitants mais de
nombreux freins subsistent comme le coût
de l'installation la réglementation
française qui se veut encore très
protectrice et surtout l'acceptation
sociale
culturellement c'est bien de dire que on
arrose les petits pois avec de l'eau de
qualité humaine que le bétail et la
fabrication du fromage elle vient à
partir de qualité d'eau humaine etc pour
pour rassurer aussi les populations donc
culturellement c'est c'est un sujet à
faire évoluer au niveau de la population
[Musique]
les Français vont devoir rapidement
s'adapter en Vendée d'ici 2023 une
technologie révolutionnaire permettra de
transformer les eaux usées en eau
potable
[Musique]
comment les fournisseurs d'eau ont-ils
accompagné les collectivités les
industriels dont le robinet était à sec
cet été réponse avec vous Patrick Betton
bonjour bonjour merci d'être là
président exécutive du groupe Sword
numéro 3 français la distribution et du
traitement de l'eau est-ce que vous avez
vous-même même si vous connaissez le
sujet été pris de cours par l'ampleur du
nombre de communes qui n'est plus une
seule goutte d'eau une centaine quand
même non alors je dirais que prix cours
non puisque le sujet de la transition
hydrique est un sujet que nous portons
depuis 3 ans c'était une de mes
convictions dès le début lorsque je suis
rentré chez sort parce que j'ai repris
la destinée de sort et je dirais que nos
7000 collaborateurs étaient sur le
terrain pour répondre aux collectivités
locales cet été c'est un été compliqué
mais qui était annoncé depuis plusieurs
années comment vous allez travailler
concrètement alors main dans la main je
sais pas mais avec les collectivités
pour faire face justement à l'urgence
quand il y avait plus d'eau dans les
dans les robinets on pense au
camion-citerne il n'y a pas que ça
j'imagine non c'est la solution extrême
oui certaines villes
ont eu des distributions je dirais d'eau
en bouteille pour pour aller chercher
une grande ville dans un futur proche on
a du mal à l'imaginer on a du mal à
imaginer mais c'est une organisation qui
est mise en place à la fois avec la
préfecture avec la mairie et avec nos
équipes ceci valable je recommande des
opérateurs sur le terrain nous avons des
des cellules de crise qui gèrent en
permanence et notamment sur la partie
estivale où nous avions une cellule de
crise 24/24 chez sort qui nous
permettait de de gérer au plus près des
collectivités ce genre de souci quoi ce
sont les collectivités Patrick béton qui
ont plus souffert que les industriels
qui peut-être ont souffert aussi
d'ailleurs les industriels ont moins
souffert je dirais
le véritable sujet en France si vous
voulez c'est quand on regarde la
consommation globale
à 10%, vous et moi c'est 10% un petit
peu de cette consommation 20%
l'industrie et 70% sur l'agriculture
donc le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
l'agriculteur des régions très agricoles
ont dû faire face je dirais une un
manque de capacité parce qu'il fallait
aussi alimenter l'ensemble des des
productions agricoles et ça tu as un
progrès sur lequel on doit s'engager sur
lequel on doit travailler avec le monde
agricole juste un petit mot encore sur
cette plateforme info sécheresse pour
que les communes se préparent en amont
j'ai découvert ton préparant l'émission
dites-moi plus là dessus info de
sécheresse donc c'est lié à cette
entreprise dont je vous parlais donc
imagéo qui nous permet de faire la
prédictabilité sur les ressources sur
les nappes phréatiques et d'orienter
c'est la consommation fonction de du
taux que nous avons sur les nappes
elles-mêmes et nous sommes dans
déploiement total sur la France avec
cette on est dans le monde digital
prédictif encore une fois que ça
fonctionne
et qui a pu prévoir encore une fois les
trois épisodes de canicule qu'on a vu
cet été nous avons annoncé à ces taux la
difficulté de l'été que nous avons en
face de nous mais c'est un sujet qui
date de 10 ans je ne sais pas un sujet
lis cet été l'été va nous permettre de
passer un nouveau cap d'un peut-être un
point de vue politique et prise de
conscience mais le sujet de la rareté il
existe depuis très longtemps maintenant
après autre sujet il y a de la
réutilisation des eaux
usagées
qui est aussi est incontournable
aujourd'hui ça sert à quoi on est
aujourd'hui encore à quoi elle sert
cette pour arroser des golfs et pour
l'idée c'est bilan de ne pas s'arrêter
là et en France où est-ce qu'on en est
ce qu'on est en retard est-ce qu'on ne
réutilise pas l'eau assez l'eau pour
justement usager pour d'autres usages
l'avenir l'avenir passera par en France
là-dessus ce n'est pas un retard je
pense qu'il y a on a d'énormes très
contraignantes d'un point de vue
sanitaire on va peut-être au-delà de ce
qu'il faudrait on en fait quoi
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on utilise l'eau je vous
donne un exemple concret pour
aujourd'hui on est sur l'île de Ré donc
parler de l'île de Ré précédemment sur
l'île de Ré on irait quelques hectares
de pommes de terre de l'île de Ré
justement avec de l'eau parce que l'on
appelle en anglais le Real donc c'est de
la rue en français donc voilà donc on
avance sur ces sujets là mais on a
encore au niveau européen des écarts sur
une sur une même entreprise pour
nettoyer des chaînes de production en
France on va utiliser de potable et au
Pays-Bas je vais utiliser de du riyude
chez soi vous êtes présent on l'a dit en
Espagne au Portugal en Arabie Saoudite
évidemment des pays où le stress
hydrique est beaucoup plus aigu que chez
nous est-ce que ça vous a permis ou ça
vous permet de développer sur place
là-bas des solutions qui vont servir
chez nous là aujourd'hui ou peut-être
dans les prochaines années dans le cadre
de notre
[Musique]
leadership sur la transition hydrique
c'est un positionnement que l'on a pris
bien sûr que les technologies je dirais
inauguré dans certains pays nous
permettront de progresser en France mais
notre enjeu principal c'est surtout sur
l'industrie comment l'eau industrielle
le traitement des eaux dans l'industrie
va nous permettre à travers des
technologies d'amener ces technologies
sur le municipal à travers des membranes
et autres parce que l'industrie nous
force à progresser
et donc nous amène à retravailler sur ce
sujet là donc en France on a beaucoup de
choses qui vont arriver prochainement et
après on finit là-dessus mais il y a
aussi la question du prix le prix l'eau
une ressource qui est de plus en plus
rare va forcément coûter de plus en plus
cher Patrick breton c'est une éluable ça
il faut s'y faire comme les prix de
l'énergie comme
j'ai souvent dit par le passé que l'eau
n'était pas assez cher quand je dis
l'eau n'est pas assez cher c'est que je
pense qu'il y a pas de prise de
conscience sur la valeur de l'eau
aujourd'hui les collectivités ont besoin
d'investir les entreprises ont besoin
d'investir et je dirais que
la population a besoin de gérer
différemment j'ai son quotidien à
travers l'eau et quand l'eau n'est pas
cher on ne fait pas attention je pense
que c'est important d'avoir ce
changement de d'habitude je pensais que
c'était terror a marqué les esprits
notamment des particuliers des ménages
des Français dans leur façon d'utiliser
l'eau certainement en haut il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un gros changement
et une prise de conscience qui a qui
évolue on doit continuer de travailler
là-dessus il y a un relais éducatif au
niveau de au niveau des écoles on doit
aussi aller dans les écoles pour
promouvoir la bonne parole mais je pense
c'est important de de d'accompagner
cette prise de conscience mais il y a
des grandes décisions qu'ils avaient
prises allez merci Patrick Gaëtan
président exécutif du groupe se remercie
à vous merci on a beaucoup parlé de
solutions pour préserver la ressource et
notamment le recyclage de l'eau
mais si la solution venait de nos océans
[Musique]
et oui puisque la Terre notre planète
bleue est faite à 72% d'eau pourquoi ne
pas dessaler nos océans bonjour Émilie
alors il se trouve que beaucoup le font
déjà les pays du Maghreb du Golfe du
Proche-Orient sauf qu'à attention au
dégâts sur l'environnement il faut
savoir que chaque jour 95 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau sont des salés à
travers le monde ce qui est loi quand on
sait que 2 milliards de personnes dans
tout simplement pas accès à l'eau mais
vous le disiez le coût écologique il est
très lourd alors il y a 50 ans c'était
vraiment la cata on était obligé de
faire bouillir l'eau de mer pour faire
de l'eau douce aujourd'hui on utilise
l'osmose inverse qui est nettement moins
énergivant qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'osmose inverse pour faire simple en
fait l'eau salée est poussée grâce à une
pompe vers une double membrane qui va
agir un petit peu comme une passoire et
qui va retenir les selles et laisser
passer les molécules d'eau donc une
passoire s'il y a bien compris en quoi
c'est mauvais pour la planète alors j'ai
envie de vous dire que c'est un petit
peu comme pour la clim en voulant régler
le problème on l'aggrave alors l'osmose
inverse pose on va dire deux problèmes
majeurs premier problème déjà il
fonctionne au fioul via des centrales
thermiques qui ont
donc soumise à des pauses notamment
quand le soleil se couche mais malgré ça
le système ne manque jamais d'eau en
fait il n'utilise pas de batterie de
stockage qui est d'ailleurs on le sait
sont très polluantes et difficilement
recyclables en fait il se base sur des
données intelligentes qui lui permettent
d'anticiper les périodes sans soleil et
puis surtout il a prévu un système de
stockage via des châteaux d'eau qui font
le plein quand le soleil brille et qui
fournissent de l'eau quand il est
défaillant alors Queen maintenant Émilie
du second problème de l'osmose inverse
c'est résidus de sel qui abîme donc le
fond des océans alors on va rappeler
déjà cosmoson produit l'eau douce à
partir d'eau salée mais aussi à partir
d'osomat c'est une ou un petit peu moins
salée qu'on va récupérer dans les nappes
phréatiques il va donc se retrouver lui
aussi avec un important stock de sel
alors pour vous donner une idée sur 100
litres d'eau de mer qui passe dans la
passoire vous avez 30 litres d'eau douce
et un substrat de sel de 35 g et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ce substrat
alors la startup tente évidemment des
solutions pour limiter l'impact sur les
écosystèmes même si on va pas se mentir
il est loin d'être neutre cet impact
alors par exemple vient un système de
dilution dans de l'eau de mer pour qu'il
soit donc moins et moins agressif et
puis autre chose on peut également jouer
sur la diffusion vous savez quand le sel
est rejeté dans la mer et bien on va le
répartir sur plusieurs endroits et non
pas sur une seule zone en jouant bien
sûr avec avec les courants marins
pourrait être une solution dans les
années à venir qui ont cesseront marquer
par des pénuries d'eau comme cet été en
France on n'est pas vraiment coutumier
du décemment mais vous le disiez vous
l'avez dit tout au long de cette
émission c'est vrai que jusqu'à présent
on était préservé même si quand même
quelques îles en Bretagne notamment
l'île de Groix ou l'île de Sein s'ils
sont mis ponctuellement elle était pour
faire face à l'afflux de touristes la
Corse qui est mis aussi un petit peu cet
été mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant
les pouvoirs publics sont pas très
chauds malgré les appels du pied de la
startup pourtant de Salma ça pourrait
vraiment être une solution de recours
une solution d'appoint dans ces périodes
de forte tension comme ça comme on l'a
vu comme on l'a vu cet été en attendant
la start-up mascara ainsi sur ce point
fondamental la priorité avant le
dessalement c'est en amont en optimisant
nos usages pour sécuriser notre
ressource en eau qui ont la vue tout au
long de cette émission et loin d'être
éternelle merci Émilie merci David voilà
pourvu que ça dure l'émission qui rend
les correspondances c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui magazine avoir au revoir sur
Public Sénat il y a du replay bien sûr
sur public senna.fr rendez-vous dans
deux semaines
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien déco des DS